interdimensional girlfriend's a death in
the family and more iconic characters
for Marvel's comics were all chopped
from marvel cinematic multiverse in
Doctor Strange yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and if you see my
review or my Easter Egg video you'll
notice I enjoyed Benedict Cumberbatch's
inception style entrance into the MCU
but now I want to look at some of the
fascinating characters scenes and
magical artifacts that didn't make it
into the final movie by the way I'm
giving away a second copy of this
awesome hardback book the mysterious
world of Doctor Strange from DK and for
a chance to win it all you have to do is
subscribe and leave a comment about the
deleted scenes on this video in case
you're wondering the book has over a
hundred and seventy pages of beautiful
illustrations and info about the crazy
characters have appeared in the Doctor
Strange comics over the years and if you
want some bonus ways to enter the
giveaway take a look at the gleam link
in the video description below
quick warning as you can imagine there
will be some spoilers in this video so
if you haven't seen the movie and want
to avoid them click up here for my
spoiler free review of Doctor Strange
Doctor Strange originally had an
introductory prologue set at CERN the
European nuclear research facility that
carries out research into particle
physics and which is also home to the
Large Hadron Collider Marvel Studios
head honcho Kevin Feige has said that
the organization's research into high
energy physics and its investigation of
the subatomic world would have been a
great real-world setting and way of
introducing fictional alternate
dimensions into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
although the CERN prologue was scrapped
for this movie Feige has said it is
possible that it might be used for
Doctor Strange sequel Hina Minori played
by actress Linda Louise Duan has a tiny
cameo in the movie but promotional TV
spots show a brief scene with her
wielding the iconic staff of wand which
is a powerful magical object in the
comics that Tina's daughter Nico
acquires and later wields speaking of
which Nico Minoru will be a lead
character marvel's TV adaptation of the
runaways on Hulu unfortunately the scene
with Tina was cut from Doctor Strange as
theatrical release though it seems
likely that it would have been part of
the sequence where Wong and his crew are
preparing to battle Kai Silius at the
Hong Kong sanctum sanctorum
Tina's character does appear a little
more in Marvel's official Doctor Strange
prelude comic where she works with
Daniel Drummond other masters from
Kamaraj to recover a magical item
the dark scepter from a thief and it
really seems that there was also an
extended scene at the Hong Kong sanctum
sanctorum that was cut from the film to
for example in the film we do see Wong
silently grabbing the wand of watoomb as
he was readying for Costa Lisa's attack
but the official b-roll for the movie
has more footage of Wang brandishing the
wand and also talking to the camera in
the theatrical release we only really
see the aftermath of the attack by
kycilia shun Hong Kong so this deleted
scene with Wong might have shown a
confrontation between Wong and the
zealots and could have filled in the gap
in the story before Wong's death there
was originally going to be an Easter egg
to the ebony blade in the movie but in
the end it was removed the ebony blade
is an enchanted sword that appeared in
the first issue of Marvel's Black Knight
comics in the movie the mystical blade
was going to be included in a magic book
called the lexicon of Runnings
but it was taken out of the script
according to the head of the art
department Barry Gibbs interestingly
there is a little Easter Egg for Black
Knights helmet among the relics and the
New York sanctum director scott
derrickson has confirmed that there was
a whole scene filmed with actress Lulu
Wilson star of Weezer
origin of evil who played Stephen
Strangers sister Donna in the comics
it's Stevens younger sister Donna who
sparks his interest in medicine after
she injures herself and he has to tend
to her and more tragically when she
accidentally drowns strange becomes a
lot more cynical and uncaring the
deleted scene with Donna would have
given more depth to strange his
backstory however derrickson has said
that it was removed because it
ultimately didn't fit with the tone of
the film after rachel mcadams was
announced as a female lead and Doctor
Strange there was speculation that she
would be playing doctor Strange's
best-known girlfriend Claire
in the comics Claire is dormammu's nice
and originates from the doc die mention
however Marvel felt that McAdams his
character should be grounded in the real
world rather than otherworldly and be
somebody who could also act as an anchor
for dr. strange in New York the
filmmakers also believed that there were
already enough new concepts to establish
in this first film Anna's Kevin Feige
put it an interdimensional girlfriend
that's the daughter of an
interdimensional demoness creature was a
step too far in introducing this world
Rachel McAdams of course plays Christine
Palmer who's just one of the characters
who've taken on the mantle of night
nurse in the
well the film does make some subtle
allusions to her comic book history as
night nurse christine parma in the movie
never uses the night nurse alias and in
fact she's actually a doctor or there's
some movie critics themed rather
confused and despite having seen the
film still think McAdams is playing a
nurse
anyway Marvel's Kevin Feige haven't
closed down rumours that Christine
Palmer may still take on the alias of
night nurse in the MCU saying that it's
just as much fun for us as it is for the
fans to speculate about that in the
post-credits scene when more dough takes
away Jonathan pangborn's magic rendering
him paralyzed once more we witness more
dough's conversion to the villainous
role that his character usually has in
the comics however concept art
reportedly shown by marvel at d23 expo
in 2015
showed strange in battle with more dough
suggesting that there were initially
plans to use more dough either as the
original villain or have him turn
against strange earlier in the movie a
possible villain cut from the film is
the tentacle demonic monster Xu McGrath
who features in Marvel's comics and was
teased by a lego set of doctor strangers
sanctum sanctorum the demon could be one
of the many weird and wonderful ideas
that the movie screenwriters Cargill and
derrickson said they originally pitched
but were asked to keep for future movies
a meal and deca star of the comedy-drama
transparent film scenes as a character
call dr. Bruner
but his scenes were confirmed by scott
derrickson as having been cut from the
final edits which suggests that there
were more scenes such at the hospital
were strange works and land Decker's
character dr. Bruner could also be an
Easter Egg to artist Frank Bruner who's
worked on numerous Doctor Strange comics
so now I'd love to know what you thought
about the deleted scenes and characters
in Doctor Strange what you think should
have stayed in the movie and what would
you like to see in a Doctor Strange
sequel be sure to leave your comments
and subscribe for a chance to win this
very cool hardback book the mysterious
world of Doctor Strange and I'll
announce the winner in a couple of weeks
and do turn on your YouTube
notifications of flicks in the city so
you can catch all my upcoming videos on
arrival fantastic beasts rogue one and
Moana and in the meantime why not take a
look at my other Doctor Strange videos
and my deleted scenes playlist click on
the links below to check them out thanks
for watching and see you next time
you'll be going movie lovers
you